hi my name is Konev kono taro from Japan
a member of the Japanese Parliament I'm
here for just over doha conference to
about our eight hours I'm gonna fly back
now better if I could redesign the world
I think the pressing issue right now is
a climate change but our in Japan and
probably other country as well some
people using this climate change issue
to press for the nuclear energy I don't
think the nuclear energy is a renewable
energy if we are to tackle this climate
change issue we have to move out of the
fossil fuels into renewable energy
directly not going via nuclear stuff so
we just talked about the energy issues
but well they don't want to touch the
nuclear I think we really have to say
alright let's not touch their nuclear
energy to jump out of the fossil fuel we
really have to go into the renewable
issues and all the government all the
NGOs and all the people have to think
about how to increase their renewable
energy so that we can stop this global
warming thank you